[Musique]
un shadow cas retrouver dans l'espace le
chapeau des jbe ceux ci en profite pour
lui insuffler de mauvaises pensées
il lui faisait voir la terre à droite
ils allaient tous à droite il lui
faisait voir la terre à gauche et ils
revenaient tous à gauche à toute vitesse
à tout bout de champ il criait tertaire
temps les autres naturellement ne voyait
rien mais j'avais confiance et j allais
et quand il arrivait et loyers
qu'effectivement il n'y avait rien
c'était quand même intéressant de sorte
que pacte ont pour ainsi dire dernier
les shadoks arrivé au prix d'incroyables
efforts de sacrifices et de souffrance
pratiquement au même pour les jbe
s'était arrêté pour les regarder
de sorte que partant de rien aussi il
arrive est en fait la même chose mais en
se donnant beaucoup moins mal il faut
aux tic
et puis un jour le shadow se mit à crier
pour de vrai car en effet il y avait
quelque chose de rond à l'avant il était
sauvé il avait là enfin devant otc de
terre
qu'ils avaient en d'espérer et dans la
solennité de leurs il oubliait les
peines endurées et en profitait pour se
pardonner les uns les autres
leur métier
et la terre grandiose et sereine
émergeait peu un peu de l'infini comme
ciel n'est c'est pour eux seuls rançon
de toutes leurs terres
[Musique]